All right. I believe, if I'm not mistaken,
that I am wive on youtube right now.
This is my second live stream in a week.
I think it's the first time
that I've ever done that. Uh,
two live streams one week.
That sounds like a naughty video
somewhere else on the Internet. Uh,
but yeah, I'm doing it
because we did the, uh,
the preelection thing couple of days ago.
I was in Stockholm,
Sweden when we did that. Right
now I am in Birmingham, UK,
well Birmingham as they
call it here apparently. Uh,
and I've got the show with Jordan Peterson
and a couple of hours. As you can see,
I'm in my hotel room. They're doing a
lot of construction in the back. Uh,
hopefully the Internet
connection will be okay.
I just want to talk a little bit about
what happened in the election and you
don't have to tell you,
it's a little weird being a,
I was in Denmark yesterday
when the election was
happening and it's really weird
being in other countries
for the last couple of days.
And I've been in different countries
almost every day from Ireland and Finland.
And Norway and Sweden and the UK,
and I'm sure I'm forgetting.
And Holland and some others I'm sure to a,
and we're going back to Sweden and
we're going back to Norway and they were
finishing up in Finland
and a couple of days, uh,
then we'll be in la and we've got a
couple more shows in Canada in December.
And then it looks like we just signed on,
I think for six or eight shows
in Australia in February.
So I'm psyched about that.
And then Jordan wants to continue
this into march and April,
so I got to see how much I can do and
maybe I'll do some more Rubin reports from
the road. And as I said, I kind of miss
doing the direct messages for you guys.
So I want to figure out how I can be
doing those a little bit more on the road.
But you've got to strike
while the irons hot.
And I'm feeling so good about everything
that's going on and there's just so
many great people that I'm meeting and
realizing that talking about all of these
things transcend borders and the concerns
of people in Norway or the same as the
concerns of the people in the United
States and Brazil and all over the place.
It's just, it's just crazy. Uh,
just a couple of other things before
I jump in on the election. Uh,
so I get back on November 12th,
fly back from Finland
and then on the 13th,
uh, I'm doing standup in Bray
California. And then on the 14th,
I'm doing standup in Oxnard,
California.
Both shows we'll have a surprise
guest from the intellectual dark web.
Uh, I'm hearing a rumor that for one of
the shows there might be two IDW members
showing up.
So I do about an hour stand up.
I bring on the guests
for about 45 minutes.
I did this with Peterson and Salt Lake
City. I've done it with Eric Weinstein.
I've done it with Christina Hoff summers.
I've done it with Bret Weinstein. Uh,
and it stand up, I promise you,
like you haven't seen before.
I do more of like a town hall situation
and get you guys involved and it's not
politically correct and it's,
and it's messy and all over the place,
but I promise you you'll have fun. So if
you're in the La area, Brae or Oxnard, uh,
the links are down below. Hope you'll
join us. We do a meet and greet after too,
if you want to say hi. Shake my hand.
Touched the hair. Oh, speaking of the air,
I left my, uh, toiletry bag in Sweden.
So for the last couple of days I have
not had any of my stuff. I had to buy,
you know, hairspray and toothbrush and
deodorant and all that. Um, but you know,
I've got my fancy schmancy hairspray
that I'd normally use this Orbay Bay dry
texturizing stuff. People are always
asking me, how do I get the lift in there?
But now I'm using this other stuff and
it's crinkly and I'm just not happy about
it. But thank you. Good people for
bearing with me. Um, okay, cool. So,
uh, so let's talk about the
election a little bit. Look,
what did I say a couple of days ago
in Sweden? They, before the election,
I said that what I thought would be best
for the country going forward would be
if the Democrats really got hammered.
If the ideas that I'm always talking about
on this show that I really care about,
that you who watch this show,
I think obviously care about that I
sense that young people care about these
days and that I also see as sort of a,
a wide new coalition of people who care
more about freedom. Then authority.
Uh, if those ideas are the
ideas that matter to you.
My hope was that the Democrats who have
embraced a real authoritarian strain
and, and really identity
politics more than anything else,
judging each other on your immutable
characteristics instead of your thoughts.
And I literally just five or 10 minutes
ago before I started this livestream,
I just a screen captured something from
the women's March where they're tweeting
about white women because not enough
white women voted for Beto to 70% of white
women voted for Ted Cruz in there.
There's any,
we've got a lot of work to do with you.
White women like this is becoming
the new racism and it's becoming
institutionalized in our
political system and in our media.
This is what I would call systemic.
It's becoming systemic, uh,
because they're going to be
passing laws about these things.
This is there going to be judging people,
uh,
based on the color of their skin and
not their immutable characteristics.
And you should not, you should care about
what people think, not how they look.
So all the headlines today were women
when we had our first Muslim congressman,
first openly gay governor of Colorado,
couple of other things. And it's like,
okay, that, that's all fine. No one care,
you shouldn't care one way or another.
It's nice I suppose. But it doesn't
matter what those conditions are.
What matters is what are they, what do
they think, what are their policies are?
So I e because I believe that identity
politics still is the biggest threat to
the west.
And by the way,
if you think I'm exaggerating this or
if you're on the fence about this or
whatever,
one of the common themes when I go to all
these different countries with Jordan,
uh, is that people are really
worried about it all over the place.
And they were worried about it
in the Scandinavian countries.
They're really worried about it.
And what's interesting about that is
the Scandinavian countries, you know,
they're predominantly white.
They now we're all dealing with
different immigration situations,
but even they are being affected by this.
So they're not even that
multicultural as a society.
They aren't the melting pot
that the United States is.
But even they are dealing with these
issues and it's all couched within the
political stuff.
And people being afraid to say what
they think and all of those things.
And then companies, you know, using this,
this diversity myth and all of
these things that actually are,
as I say,
to institutionalize and racism where
Harvard won't have Asian applicants and
where companies will say, we're going
to have half women and we're like,
is it that you're going to have the exact
proportion of gay people and women and
black people and Muslims and Jews and all
of these things and Dah, Dah, Dah, Dah,
Dah. And then you think what?
That your product will be better.
Do you think your society will be
fairer or or more just or good.
It will be worse than ever.
Not only will your product
be worst because you won't
be hiring people based on
skill. You'll be hiring them based
on those immutable characteristics,
but you won't be providing more of a,
more of a tolerant society.
You'll be creating an intolerant society
where people will look at each other
neighbor,
we'll look at neighbor and be jealous
or angry or expect something of someone
else. So it's so it's
super dangerous. So anyway,
what I said before the election was that
what I think the best thing is for the
things that I care about and
for a return to liberalism,
a left that was liberal,
that had a live and let live attitude,
but believed there was a right
way to use the government, uh,
to, to create a grand
society, let's say, uh,
that has nothing to do
with the left anymore.
So my feeling was these guys have to be
destroyed. I don't want to hurt people.
I want the ideas to be rejected
so that better ideas could come.
So as I laid it out the other
day, what I would say is if, if,
if this leftist monster had been
destroyed out of the ashes of that,
and this is a little bit of sort of
like a Jordan Peterson style, uh,
religious resurrection
out of the ashes of that,
perhaps a Phoenix could come forth.
Perhaps there would be a
rebirth of liberalism. Now,
unfortunately that's not what happened.
Now look,
it's interesting what happened here
because the Democrat there was definitely
not a blue wave. So let's
be clear on that. You know,
everybody was predicting the blue
wave, the blue wave, the blue wave.
And as I said the other day,
it's like anyone that's predicting
anything with certainty,
nobody had any clue what was going on.
And we can all play armchair
quarterback and we can all,
we can all pretend the day after
we knew exactly what was going on.
But that's pretty rare and far between.
And especially these days,
it's hard to garner what's
going on with the Poles.
My hope you take out the dangerous
elements of the Democratic Party,
they returned to liberalism and then
they're returned to a bit of a centrism
would then cause some of the right,
the bad elements of the right,
say the white nationalist parts of right,
which by the way,
I don't think our systemic or massive or
that influential, uh, but they do exist.
But then maybe if the, if the left
came a little closer to the center,
it would be a little bit easier for the
right to read itself if some of it's bad
elements. And what I also thought
was that maybe if that had happened,
Trump then would be feeling really good.
Like he could do what he wanted for
the next two years and that may be,
he then would realize you don't have to
run on trolling on Twitter all the time
and fighting media all the
time and all of those things.
Cause I do think we're going to eventually
get to diminishing returns on that.
Cause I don't think the society
can run on that forever.
I just don't think it's possible.
And that may be then Trump would
actually moderate some of the language.
And I think most people,
although it's hard to get say the
Hashtag resistance people to admit this,
but I think most people realize the
policies of Trump, even if you're a lefty,
haven't been that bad.
Um,
the rhetoric and what you may think
of him as a person and all that,
that's a different story. So that was,
that was my hope. Now what happened? Okay.
So the Democrats got the house back
last I heard. I think it's around, uh,
they got at least 26 seats back, but
they're still waiting to find out more.
Republicans picked up a
couple of [inaudible] in the
Senate. So look, number one,
the real risk of this whole thing would
have been that there had been a blue
wave,
um,
to the point where the Republican or
the Democrats would have taken the house
and taking the Senate and then we
would've had impeachment of Trump.
There is just no doubt and what that
would have led to. I really believe this,
and I didn't want to say this over the
last couple of weeks cause I don't like
teasing out ideas so that they gain
momentum. Scary ideas, let's say. Um,
is that we would have ended up in sort
of a low grade cold civil war in America
if that would've happened.
Now,
fortunately because the Republicans at
least kept the Senate and I say this as
someone that has never even
really voted Republican, um,
which I think is worth mentioning
over and over cause it seems like I'm
defending the Republican's were that, um,
that I am a Republican and I'm not, um,
otherwise generally think their
ideas are better at the moment. Um,
but had, had they lost both
the house and the Senate,
we'd be in a really dangerous place today.
I think we would actually have some
serious, serious problems on our hands.
That did not happen. The fact that
the Republicans kept the Senate, uh,
basically we won't have impeachment.
They, the Democrats may try to bring,
you know, some other investigations
on Trump and that sort of thing. Um,
look,
so the danger right now is this,
if you're with me on this identity
politics stuff, if you're with me,
that the left is no longer liberal
and, and all of these ideas, um,
there's no reason to think they're not
going to double down again on those ideas.
They doubled down when they lost last
time to Trump and now they've gained some
seats. So I think there's no reason that
they wouldn't double down and say, see,
there's a winning, there's
a winning, um, path.
If we keep up with this. And that's
what I think the problem is right now.
And as I said the other day,
what I think that will lead to is
more and more decent liberals going,
okay, you know what? I can't have
a conversation with these people.
Because every time I open my mouth they
tell me I'm a bigot and a racist in the
rest of it.
Just look what the women's march just
tweeted before I started this livestream.
And what I will do is be willing to talk
to Libertarians and Conservatives and
Magda people and the never Trump people,
because at least they're a little
willing to talk about these things.
So I still think there will be
a wide tent developing there.
I also think it's possible if the house
goes so bananas on some of the Anti
Trump stuff,
that that then helps Trump get
reelected because it fires up the base.
I did see an interesting,
uh,
tweet where somebody laid out how many,
how seats the incumbent president's
party lost during midterms.
And for Obama, he was extremely
high. Clinton, Hi George.
H W and W hi Clinton high. Uh, but for,
for Trump it was actually the
lowest since something like 1946.
Um,
so that,
that's just an interesting piece of
information relative to all of this.
I suppose I saw some people saying that
that could potentially have something to
do with Jerry Jerry mandering.
I would need to do a little bit more
research on that. Uh, but in any event,
I think basically right now we're pretty
much in the same place we were a couple
of days ago where there was no evidence
really that the left was going to stop
going off the deep end.
Now they're emboldened a little bit
and we'll see what the responses on the
other side.
I think Trump may be even speaking right
now or he was going to speak in the
next hour or so to address,
uh, you know, his thoughts
after the election. Um, but I,
I just want to,
I'll take some questions by the way.
So it's patrion.com/reuben recording.
I'll take some questions that if you want
to jump in on super chat, I will, uh,
I'll take some on there as well.
I've got a trusty Google doc here and
my guy as her back in adolescence,
so I will jump in on that in
just a second. Um, but, you know,
one of the other things that I was
thinking as I was looking at Twitter and
trying to track some of the news,
and again,
it's weird being in other countries
when this is all happening, right?
Like I live and breathe
this thing and it was weird,
like laying in bed last night at like
two in the morning watching Danish
television, um, talk
about American elections.
So then finally I couldn't take
it anymore. So I switched to,
I watch Scarface and then I
watched, uh, the big Lebowski,
both far more entertaining than Danish
coverage of the American elections. Um,
but, but every country that we've
been in, Finland, Sweden, Holland, uh,
here in the UK,
obviously the obsession with American
politics doesn't strike me as good and
healthy for, for these countries.
North America itself. I mean,
we really still are the engine and
I think we should be really, um,
we should be careful and we should
to be responsible about what that,
what that means for the world.
If we're the engine of how
ideas get put out there.
If our culture in our movies
and our music and our,
our political discourse and everything
is where it all starts and that is,
that is where it seems to be,
then I think we do have to be
careful and it's like, look,
we had an election yesterday and everyone
said they hate each other and today
everyone's,
you know,
some people are dancing on other people's
graves and other people are upset and
this and that. We're not killing each
other on the streets. Do not forget that.
Do not forget that. That is the important
thing here. Democracy is still working.
It is imperfect. It is messy. You should
fight for the things you believe in,
but it's still working. Um,
so, so see what happens.
I also just want to say one other thing
quickly before I get to a couple of
questions, which is that, you know,
it seems that politics just always brings
out the worst in us and it seems that
it usually brings out the worst in us
in Twitter. And I'm really, really,
really, really going to commit
to being better than it.
And it sometimes gets me, like sometimes
someone says something so stupid,
I got to own them,
or someone says saying so dishonest or
someone goes after me or whatever it is.
Um, and I usually ignore most
of it or I try not to add to it.
Or even when I do something, I try
to do it with a little bit, uh,
a little bit of sarcasm or snark instead
of just like straight up vitriol.
I mean, I really never do that. I don't
think, um, not to say I have never,
I'm sure I have, but, uh, I'm really
gonna try not to add to the, uh,
to the fire because I think we need some
more firefighters these days. And a,
I'm going to really try and
I hope you'll try and, uh,
and we'll see it because I do think
we can win more people by just being a
little bit better. I really do. So I'm
going to keep trying that. All right.
Let me get to a couple of questions.
So first we're going to
jump on patrion question.
So it's patrion.com/ruben report and a,
and then we'll take some
super chat questions as well.
If you want to get hurt,
you can jump in on there. Um, so
feel free to do that. Reminder.
Just real quick. Uh, I am back in La on
a November 12th and then on the 13th,
I am doing standup at, uh, the Bray Improv
and then I'm at liberty live in Oxnard,
California. Both are outside of La. Uh,
and I will have an IDW guest with
me on both days. Oh, by the way,
if you sign up on Patrion at Ruben select
level three or higher, you get a free,
you get free entrance into my meet and
greet and I hang out with people after
the show. Oh, real quick. Then I
promise I'll get to the questions. Uh,
so we do these meet and greets after
the show. And Jordan does these,
these really extended meet and greets.
It's usually about a hundred people
might have 20, 30, 40 or so, usually,
sometimes a little bit less. It
depends. Um, and uh, the Sweden one,
we had like 50 people and it was so
cool. We had this huge, huge table.
We standing room only and I kind of
held court and it was just great.
It was just so much fun. Like I really
feel like being on this tour, it's, it's,
it's changed me in that like I really
am meeting and connecting with so many
great people all over the world and
people are coming up to us all over the
place and sometimes Jordan
goes out, uh, into the, into
the audience, into the line,
outside the theater
before we start. And, uh,
and we're messing around with
the crowds and we're just,
we're just having a blast.
So I hope you guys will come to the
shows if you haven't, if you haven't yet.
And it looks like we're going to be
doing Germany and Belgium and uh,
and Turkey and Israel and
all over the place. I mean,
it seems like we're just going to keep
going and going so we shall see what
happens. Okay. Um, I
live in rural America.
How can I balance my libertarian
philosophy with the fact
that the population in
my area can't support the kinds of school
and infrastructure investments that
will provide the equality of opportunity
that is so important to me and my
offering?
What a great question because what you're
saying basically is your libertarian,
so you want local, local, local,
but in a rural area like that,
there may not be enough money to actually
fund the types of things that you want.
So this is a, this is a really good one.
This is a place where I would say you,
you and your local representatives,
um,
should be fighting as much as possible
that depending on what state you live in
to get your,
uh,
your local area more resources or
you move. Right? So that's the,
that's the easy answer is you move.
If they're,
if the resources aren't right for
your area and your libertarian,
you move somewhere else, you use
your foot boat, you move. Okay.
But putting that one aside, uh,
you know, I'm from New York.
So New York has an interesting thing
part of this because there's a constant
battle between the mayor of New York
City and where there are some odd,
you know,
I think it's around 8 million people.
And then the governor of New
York who's up in Albany, upstate,
who has to deal with the entire state,
where there's huge rural areas and
there's farms and huge distances between
people. There's the, uh, the southern
tier area. I went to Suny Binghamton, so,
uh, southern interior area, which is
part of upstate New York, is really,
really economically depressed right now.
So there's a constant battle between
the governor who has to take care of the
entire state and the mayor of New York
City who has the most people there.
So he argues that he needs the most
resources and how do you allocate all of
that? And it's like there's such
a concentration of people there.
You could see a governor going well
rested to stay in votes right down there.
Um,
so the best thing you can do is laugh.
Hopefully you have a decent local
representative of decent state senator,
let's say. And you can get them to
lobby for more resources in your area.
I would say there's,
you know,
there's probably other ways maybe through
homeschooling a little bit or online
learning, things like that.
But if it's really bad,
like if you live in an area that's really
being ignored and you've tried to fix
it, you know, sometimes you
just got to go. And again,
this is, this is Shitty, right?
This is the argument that I make about
why I wouldn't force the baker to make
the, the cake for the
gay wedding. It's like,
I don't want the government coming in
and telling a private company what to do,
what service to offer.
Um,
and if you happen to live in a town where
the only Baker won't be you, the cake,
the specific cake for your
wedding, uh, well then you,
you can either get a cake
online and that works, right?
That does work and it
doesn't feel great probably,
but it does work or you
can move. So, you know,
it's a really great question because it
sort of puts your beliefs to the test
and that's kind of what it's all about.
And you should try to live in a place
where the ideas and the ideals that you
care about are rewarded and
are then feel like they matter.
Um, so that's a, it's a
really great question. Um,
and I don't know that there's really a,
like a perfectly right answer to that.
It's sort of also what do you need?
Like if you really value say, oh,
the land you live on and the freedom that
that affords you and things like that,
maybe then that overrides some of the
other issues that you're talking about.
It's interesting. Um,
let's see. Super Chat.
I asked him pool this yesterday.
Do you think it's smart for the Dems to
portray Trump as the worst international
as the worst to the international
community as Americans? Hello?
From Australia by the way? Oh,
well first off, as I just said,
I think I just said it. Uh,
we're going to Australia,
I think six or eight stops in February,
so I'll let you know about that.
It's somewhere between
like February 6th and 18th.
We're trying to figure it all out. So I
hope you'll come to one of the shows. Um,
do I think it's a good move for them to
play it off that internationally Trump
is the worst? Not really, because
internationally right now,
look, Trump has done pretty good work
with Nikki Haley at the UN to really just
completely decimate a seriously corrupt
organization that makes the Legion of
doom looks, look like, um, you know,
Barney's playhouse for your site
because Barney have a play house,
something like that.
Um,
so internationally I do sense that some
of our allies actually trust us a little
bit more right now. You know, I think the,
the Obama red line in Syria thing was
one of the worst foreign policy mistakes
probably in 50 years because our allies
suddenly trusted us less cause he said,
if you, if you use chemical weapons,
that's our red line. And then they did.
And we didn't do anything. Not that I
wanted to do anything. You can go back,
you know, five years ago and watch when
the Syria war was really heating up.
You can watch videos of
me on the young Turks, uh,
talking about how I did not want the
United States to be involved at all,
that sometimes other countries surrounding
countries like Saudi Arabia and
Turkey should get involved and at,
and perhaps the United States could
offer a little bit of a humanitarian
corridor for people to go
to, but that would be it. Um,
so I don't know that painting
him, uh, more scarily,
let's say to the international
community would work. Look,
he's talking to North Korea
right now. Um, you know, we,
we've ridden some of these trade deals.
Yeah.
There's still like the personality
element that's still a little bizarre. Uh,
maybe you can play that up.
I'm not,
I just don't know that it's a winnable
strategy though. Let's see. All right,
I'll jump in one more. Um,
one more super chat, uh,
opinion of Florida giving
felons the right to vote. Yes.
So I just heard about this one.
So I guess there was a referendum on
this and felons who could not vote.
Now we'll be able to vote.
Look if you've done your time,
you are still a citizen of
the United States of America.
So I don't really see a
counter argument to that. Um,
I suppose if you did something that
was directly related to election fraud
perhaps or something like that,
but let's say you're a felon,
you're an armed robber. You
are, you robbed a bank, you
know, you serve your time,
you serve 10 years,
you're now 38,
you get out of jail and you're
trying to rebuild your life.
Should you never be allowed to take
part in the election process again,
I don't see how that is fair.
So basically I would need to know a little
bit more about the specifics of this,
but basically I think it's actually
totally fine. Um, let's see. Dave,
why don't you do an all tech
week like a youtube or weak, uh,
interview the guys behind bitch,
shoot gab minds, et cetera.
So I've been thinking about
doing something like this
because it's obviously so
much of what's going on here
now politically, culturally,
technologically is directly related to
the ways that we can communicate. Right?
I'm sitting on my laptop computer,
which is on top of a small
garbage can by the way, uh, in,
in Birmingham a UK and you guys are
watching this all over the world.
That's incredibly cool. Uh, but if
the company's in this case, Google,
uh,
that,
that own the pipes and own the wires
and on the Wifi and own the airwaves and
all of that stuff,
if they want to slowly clamped
down on certain types of speech,
which I think there is evidence that they
would like to do some of that at least
a little bit. Um, then we
should be talking about
alternative technologies here.
As you guys know from my talks with Peter
Teal and I talked with Eric Weinstein
and a couple others, uh, there's plenty
of discussion in this, in this arena.
I can't give you all the discussion about
that, that I'm privy to at the moment.
Um,
but I do think that's a good idea,
actually get some of the cool tech
people in here to discuss some of these
things. Maybe I can smoke a blunt
with Elon Musk. All right. Let's see.
Um, okay. Oh and a reminder,
I've already printed out twice,
but the links to the brayer show on the
13th and the oxygen art show on the 14th
are write down below.
Uh,
so I hope you guys will join me for some
stand up and meet some of the IDW crew.
All right.
Shouldn't we stick around and fight to
reform and push back on the left also
because of what you're seeing out there.
How do you feel about the possibility
of a third party that might just be able
to rise? Look, the, the
stay and push back thing?
I think there are great arguments
on both sides. So Eric Weinstein,
who is become like a brother to me,
who is one of the greatest
minds I think on earth, uh,
he still considers himself part of the
left and he believes that it can be
reformed from the inside.
I see no evidence of it.
And not only do I see no evidence of it,
I see a continued slow,
uh, slide to all of the
things that I don't like.
And I see more and more people get
purged for any sort of free thought.
I see them using the
ideas of collectivism, uh,
which is a type of racism actually,
and it is a type of sexism
and is a type of bigotry.
I see them using those ideas
more and more and more. Again,
go check the women's March tweet that I
just sent out right before this stream.
White women, you know, we're
coming for you, white women.
If you don't do what we want you to do,
we're for women or for women. Know that,
but you better do what we want you to do.
Otherwise we're not for you then.
Which is why saying you're for women or
you're for gay people or your for black
people is actually stupid. It's,
it's not a clear thought out,
logical argument. Because if
you're for it doesn't make sense.
Women think different things.
Black people think different things.
Gay people think different things.
So what can you be for? Oh my God,
the broken record of you can be for the
individual. That's what you can be four.
So as for staying look, let's say, let's
say Eric's right and I'm wrong, and,
and a couple bandits inside the left can
can blow up the machine and fix it and
everything else.
And suddenly JFK liberals are
all over the place and you know,
they believe in somewhat of
a slim or trim or government,
but they don't think governments
the answer to everything.
They don't believe in identity
politics, et Cetera, et cetera.
That would be freaking spectacular.
And I will gladly say, man, good.
You guys did it. Fantastic.
What I can see is it's, it's,
it wouldn't be honest of me to say
that I am part of that anymore.
I'm just not. And not only am I not, but,
but me and all of my crew
that you guys all know,
none of us get invited to anything
on the left by college campuses or
organizations or anything. We get
invited by conservatives and we look,
Eric Weinstein and I spoke
at the iron ran institute.
Iron rand is a basically a libertarian
organization. There's a little,
there's obviously more to objectivism
than just that, but they're,
they're pretty far on the right.
Especially on economics. Um, and,
and Eric went up there and said all
sorts of things against libertarianism,
against objectivism, against iron rand
and her writing and all sorts of stuff,
and got a huge ovation after.
And then we had a cocktail hour and
everybody was having a great time. I mean,
you've simply never see that on the
other side. So, and this is also aware,
you know, we all get invited on Fox News
and I go on because they don't edit me.
And I go on Tucker live and I go on Greg
Gutfeld live and we don't get invited
to CNN or MSNBC,
so that it just is what it is.
So I will find allies were allies are,
and if I keep putting my hand out to one
side and they keep biting me and I keep
putting up my hand out to another side,
and where I see that they are,
they are malleable. That there, that the
young conservatives look at Kyle cashew,
who I had on the show last week
of brilliant young kid. Uh,
and they don't care about
gay marriage anymore. They,
they don't really care about marijuana.
I think there,
even though most of them
I think are prolife,
they're willing to have a discussion
about, uh, about abortion.
They're willing to have a discussion
about dignity with debt and things of that
nature.
So I will go and talk to those people
because they're willing to talk to me.
And I'm also, I'm also confident in what
I believe in and what my knowledge is.
And I believe if I sit down with
people, you know, there's this idea,
I think people on the left are so afraid
that if you sit down with someone there,
they're going to trick you and you're
going to become one of them. But I'm,
I'm as confident in my ideas
as they probably are in theirs,
and I believe we can have that out.
And I'm not afraid of that.
So I think you can make a good argument
the way, as for the third party thing,
look, this is the, this is
the really, really tough part.
If you're a libertarian these days,
if you're a libertarian,
I could see why you'd say, you
know what? Forget the Republicans.
They keep putting everything else
aside for getting Trump all that.
They always spend more, right.
They talk about smaller government,
but they always spend more,
even when they cut taxes,
they're still spending
more including Trump.
So I can see why you'd
want to be a third party.
And I thought Larry Sharp did a really
nice job in New York and he busted his
ass. And you know what, he didn't
even get 2%. It's very unfortunate.
He was on my show.
He was on Rogan's show.
He didn't get any mainstream
coverage really. Uh, but he really,
really did try and he's a good guy and I,
I,
I hope he has a bright future in front
of them and I'm sure we'll cross paths
again. Um, now the inherent
problem with this is, okay,
so if the Libertarian party really
imagine if they really pull it together,
they get some great,
you know,
dynamic young person and
people to run down ticket too.
Because part of their problem is they
do very little down ticket and then they
throw someone for, uh, you know, for
presidency and then it just looks stupid.
Um, that the problem is that, all right,
so let's say they do the most amazing,
uh, returns ever for, for Libertarians.
Let's say they get 10% 12%. Well, what
do I mean? You've taken at least eight,
9% of that from Republicans and you
guarantee the Democrats win and then,
and then that's not good. Now, I
discussed this with Larry Sharpen.
What he would say is you've got to
do that because otherwise you're,
you'll just never change. And I think
that's an interesting argument, right?
Like you've got to go,
we're going to get 10% this time,
but lose knowing that hopefully next time
we'll have a little momentum and maybe
we can get it to 18% then maybe after
that we can get it to 28% and then maybe
get to a tipping point and we go from
24% to 41% or something like that.
I think that's a totally legit
argument. Um, can we survive, you know,
um, you know, 10, 12,
14 years of what that will do
with this new left in charge.
I Dunno. But I would also
say the same point I'm been,
the left is dealing with this themselves.
It's like the old school liberals
who are at this point, um,
and the, and the progressive's have very
little in common. So what is your party,
which isn't going to be run by
and perhaps they need to split,
let the progressive have the far
left stuff, let them have it,
and maybe that is worth and lent
and it's for them, but all right,
let them have it and then, and have sort
of the more old school liberal party,
let Joe Biden run a party for his
last, you know, it'd be Grandpa,
the old liberals or
whatever. I Dunno. I Dunno.
And then they'd have to deal with fame
reckoning, right. That I just mentioned,
because then they would ensure basically
that a Republican party comes back.
So I guess the best answer is that the
both parties would do it at the exact
same time. Pretty rare. It's a tough
question. And it's one of those things,
it's like, it's, it's just a matter of
how much risk are you willing to take,
I think, uh, in your
decision making. Okay. Uh,
any plans on coming to the capital
of decentralized power Switzerland?
I don't know why Switzerland
wasn't on the list here. Uh,
I will ask Jordan tonight and I will
find out, hang tight on that one. Um,
let's see.
Uh,
have you considered interviewing
conservatives who are
more skeptical of a free
market economics like Roger
Scruton or Peter Hitchens?
I'd love to interview scrutiny.
Uh, Jordan had lunch with,
or dinner with him a couple
of days ago and I was invited,
but I ended up going back to London
to do something. Um, but we're,
we're connected now, so hang tight.
I hope I can work that one out.
And Peter Hitchens and I,
we've traded a couple emails.
I really wanted to do it in
studio. Like, you know what,
maybe I can do it next time.
I'm, uh, I'm in London,
I think he lives in London
and I actually have,
I have a day off in London tomorrow. I'm
doing something really cool. Actually,
if you guys remember my, um, my
interview with Katherine Verbal Sing,
which was in August, uh, she is, uh,
she's an educator who created
her own charter school,
the Mckayla school here in London.
And they're doing just great work
helping kids get out of poverty,
helping families, uh, really showing what
personal responsibility is all about.
Their kids are getting great
grades. They're, they're
actually teaching and it's,
and it sounds like it's just a wonderful
school and I was totally inspired by
her, so I'm going to go take a tour of
the school tomorrow with her and then, uh,
I'm going to speak to some of the kids in
the afternoon, which is pretty cool. Um,
but maybe I can reach out to Peter and
see if I can at least maybe just meet
them for coffee or tea as they have here
and in London. And then we will see. Um,
let's see. Uh, hey Dave, do you think the
Phoenix rising from the ashes scenario,
we'll actually need to happen through
a complete leftist takeover as ran
projects. Uh, whereas ran projects in
atlas shrugged. Do you think leftists,
we'll have to see the toxicity of their
policies play out before they're willing
to abandon them. Yeah. You know,
it's like, and that's why I say it,
I started at the beginning of this thing,
I think by the Democrats
getting the House here,
but we're going to get is sort of just
this slow descent into more of this
nonsense where I would say at this point
the most healthy thing would have been
a destruction of a weird couple of years
where they would've had to reconstitute
the party and have a read,
have the real fight.
Like we're not doing anything real right
now. We're not having the real fights.
We should be, we should be willing
to have real political fights,
not just sort of political bickering over,
over winning points.
Um, so I think yes, like, well again,
this is why this tweet that the women's
march just sent down from White Women
Watch out,
white women were looking at you.
If you don't do what we want you to do,
it's why it's so dangerous
and so actually racist and,
and, and it's inherently anti freedom. Um,
so I think that enough of them
will have to start seeing that.
Like if the next move,
what the left does is it eats a group
and then eats a group and then eats a
group and then eats a group
and then eats a group. Well,
if the next move now is
they've sort of white men,
they've been going after white men for
a long time. If the next move is right,
we're going to go after white women.
Maybe some white women will start waking
up and go, wait a minute, wait a minute.
I don't, I don't have to vote.
If I'm prolife let's say,
and I'm conservative on this or that or,
and I want lower taxes and
states' rights and, uh,
whatever it is, I don't have to
be part of the women's March.
I don't have to, and I won't be guilted
into it. And then when you corner them,
they start coming out stronger. So I think
that that's, that's possible. I mean,
think about it, the women's March.
So that means there are four women,
or are they for Nikki Haley,
who I think is, you know,
I'd probably vote for president and
who I think is one of the strongest,
you're Republican governor
of South Carolina goes into
the UN and is the u s rep
there and just cracked skulls.
Um,
and who has just been a spectacular
fighter for American values and who comes
from an immigrant family and all of
these things that America is all about.
Are they for her? They're not. So
don't tell me you're for women,
you're for women who behave as
you wish them to behave. Um,
let's see.
How much do you think late night comedy
shows like Stephen Colbert, John Oliver,
Samantha Bee Affect election results?
I would say very little. Very little.
I can't imagine, you know, I think
they're mostly preaching to the choir. Uh,
one of the things that I'm so proud of
is that I still to this day and always
for the last couple of years,
I get emails from people of every
political persuasion in every country,
gay, straight, black, blah,
blah, blah, doesn't matter,
but that are all over the place.
Some that are,
that are now waking up to what
they see with, you know, I'm left.
I've been a lefty my whole life.
I'm now waking up to this.
And then I get emails from Christian
conservatives and I get emails from
Libertarians and all of these different
people who are all at different stages
of this.
And I think part of the reason for that
is that we're having honest conversation
here. I am not, I'm telling you what
I think for better or worse, you're,
you're sharing your questions
with me or your comments.
We're doing this in long form.
You can hear something that I'm doing and
then take an idea and then perhaps Sam
Harris is going to talk about it in a
different way or in a way that I disagree
with on his podcast. You're going to see
Eric Weinstein and I disagree on things.
You're going to watch Joe Rogan and I
talk about different things and you're
going to be able to
formulate your thoughts.
Those shows are not really
places of formulating thought.
They're all sort of that, that, uh, that,
uh, Trump that, that a, that a Trump like,
it's not that interesting or funny or
amusing. So I don't think people really,
I think a certain amount of people may
be guilted into voting a little bit by
them, but I don't think people really pay
attention to it, which is, which is nice.
Uh, Dave, when will AI become an election
issue? Oh Man, what a great question. Um,
I would say that by 20,
let's say by 2024, it'll be the
big one. I don't think it'll,
I don't think by, in two years, in
2020 it'll be a big issue. It'll,
it'll have move forward a
little bit for sure. Um,
and with more automation comes more
issues about the economy and minimum wage
and all sorts of things
and ubi and whatever else.
But I don't think it'll be huge in
two years. I would say the election,
the presidential election
after that. So say 20, 24, I
think that'll be bicycle. Uh,
how do I get you to come to my school?
So I'm going all over the place. Uh,
and when I'm, when I'm not with JP, I'm
traveling and doing schools by myself. Uh,
you can go to Dave rubin.com/contact
and, uh, putting the request,
I send it over to my agents and
then as long as we can work it out,
works with my schedule and everything
else, we're good to go. Um,
let's see. Dave, take a break
and place them pub g with me.
I don't know what that
is. I'm getting old. Um,
are you excited for super smash brothers
ultimate or is that not your thing?
I've played smash brothers a bunch and
you know, as I always tell you guys,
I don't really have time for
video games anymore. Um, I,
I completely like little
bites here and there.
I've been playing a little NBA live,
uh, with my brother and my nephew. Um,
but I don't have really time. But,
so a game like smash brothers,
I can play a quick cause I can play it
with a couple of friends right there and
we can do it and it's totally fun.
Um,
people keep asking for my playstation
names so that we can connect on there.
Maybe, maybe one day when I like
take a weird, you know, all this,
when I go off the grid,
maybe I would take like two days and
make them like video game days and I'll,
I'll play with you guys all over the
place. That actually could be kind of fun.
Um, oh, I do want to give you a
little, uh, a little career, uh,
tip or not tip.
I want to give you a little career hint
as to something good that's happened,
but I'll wait, uh, towards
the end to do that.
But a lot of good things are
happening. All right. Let's see. Uh,
I've been saying for a long time that if
Trump would dial back the rhetoric from
an 11 to an eight and reduce
the personal ad hominem attacks,
he would attract another 10 to 20% of
the electorate from the middle that
dismisses him because of the
behavior. Your thoughts. Yeah.
I basically agree with you now. I
think he sort of, at some level,
he sort of needed to do it.
When he was running the first time,
he had to break through
the political correctness.
He had to break through the main stream
media. He had to garner the attention.
All of those things.
Now that he's president,
especially because things
are going basically, okay,
the economy is chugging along.
We're not going into extra wars.
We're redoing some of the trade
deals, things of that nature. Okay.
Be Things we're basically
going, okay, you know,
net neutrality and no one's been killed.
The Paris accords were not dying,
et Cetera, et cetera.
It would be interesting,
and this is why I was saying if
the Republicans would have won,
that might've given him enough breathing
room to start doing that dial back.
Some of the rhetoric, you don't
have to just be the troll in chief.
So hopefully I think there's still a
way for him to do that because if the
Democrats now go, you know, feel really
emboldened and they think, all right,
well now we can, we can attack Trump.
We can still try for impeachment,
even though it would be an impossibility.
Whatever else it is. And then Trump,
imagine if he steps back.
Sorry about that light over there.
Imagine if he steps back and it's
like, you know what? I'm going to,
I'm going to be the more mature
party here. I can't believe it.
Nobody else could believe it, but
I'm going to try it. That would,
I think help him that he's not
the people that want the trolling,
the people that want to own the
live towards and all that stuff.
He's got them pretty much not going to
lose them because those people aren't
gonna go to the left.
So you got those guys.
So there's a way to get the other people
that are concerned with digital subtly.
I think about sort of the trolling and
some of the rhetoric and that kind of
stuff. I know plenty of those people
because I think there's actually,
I think you know, the 10 to 20%
you mentioned here, I think,
I think that's a pretty fair number
because I know plenty of people right now,
lefties, liberals, let's say,
who when I talk to privately they're like,
you know,
I don't think things
that are bad right now.
I think things were kind
of all right actually,
and I have a little more money
in my paycheck and my Ira,
these are 401k is doing
right or blah, blah, blah,
investments are doing all right.
Um, but I don't like the rhetoric
and they can't get over that,
so why keep giving it
to them? I don't. And,
and it would be nice if we had a little
more return to normalcy in terms of the
rhetoric because again,
I don't think we can last on this,
this sort of crazy tenor forever. I just
don't think it's possible. All right,
we've got
15 minutes reminder,
paypal. I'm doing stand up again.
I don't know why, but it's been,
it's been awesome. We've sold out
every single show that we've done. Uh,
and they're great. I do about an hour
stand up. I get you guys involved.
We do giveaways and it's fine. It's
like no standups are you've ever seen.
I promise you a,
so I will be in a Braya
California on November 13th.
The link is right down below
and then I'll be in Oxnard,
California on the 14th
link right down below.
I've got an IDW character joining me for
both shows and I'm hearing a rumor that
there might be a second one.
So I do hope you'll join me.
And if you join at patrion.com/rubin
report on a level three or higher,
you get a free meet and greet.
I will shake your hand.
I will take a picture with you. Sometimes
people hugged me, which is always,
as long as you don't hug for too long,
there's always that moment where the
hug goes from like, oh, that's nice.
You're a stranger.
You're showing me affection to like La.
We better ease up on that. Um, but
yeah, so we can do all that. Let's see.
Democrats,
bed power in California for decades and
things have gotten worse for the middle
class. What hope do you see in California
now that Newson will be governor? Yeah,
I mean, I'm not very hopeful actually. Uh,
which is ironic because I love
living in Los Angeles and, uh,
I can tell you that even
in ELA there has been an,
he's just becoming governor now,
but the amount of homeless people
has increased tremendously. Um, will,
last time I was in Berkeley, uh, our car
got broken into on a pretty nice street.
We were at a steak joint.
The car got broken into basically in front
of the state, join Morton steakhouse,
so like a nice place and they
stole, stole my bag. Um, my,
my, uh, sisters, parents, uh,
my sisters parents in law, uh, were
visiting from out of the country.
They were in Berkeley just a couple of
weeks ago and they got mugged in broad
daylight.
They literally ripped the rings off
my brother-in-law's mother's fingers.
Um, pretty violent. I mean, she was
bruised the whole, the whole thing. Um,
so I think there's some bad trends
in California for sure. I mean in,
in San Francisco they've got an app
to tell you where human poop is on the
street. I am not making that up. Um, I
saw somebody shooting up in Berkeley,
like on a, on a side street. Um,
so there's a lot of trends that are bad
in California. Goo Newsome got good hair,
he's got a nice smile as all the right
things, but he's for big government,
he thinks that government can resolve
all of these things and I don't think
government can, I think
government basically makes
all of these things worse. Um,
so I'm not very hopeful unfortunately
for California cause it,
which sucks because I love living in
California and you can't beat the weather
and I really do like the people.
And in La there's a resurgence of some
interesting political conversation
happening. I mean, you know,
Shapiro's here in La and Dennis Prager's
here in La and Peter teals here in La
and Sam Harris is here in La and,
and plenty of other people
out here in La Right now.
So there is an interesting
interview, cool. A set
happening in La and I, you know,
it's just unfortunate, but, uh, if
somebody wants me to move to Texas,
make me an offer. I can't
refuse a, okay, let's see. Um,
uh, oh, pub g is player unknown
battleground for ps four.
I don't know what it is,
but I'll check it out.
But if someone give me like a contrast
style game that I can just blow some
stuff up and hopefully it's
a side scroller I would love
to or, or a more like a,
like a life force. Gravity is kind of
shooter, but I want to go that way.
I don't want to go that way. Can't go
that way. Don't want to go this way.
I want to go that way. Or I guess I'd go
that way, but can't do it the other way.
Um, do, do, do. All right, let's see. Um,
are there any future endeavors with
Brett, Eric and or Heather? Well,
I don't want to give away too much,
but I just told you that, uh, you know,
potentially there are some IDW people
joining me for my standup Gigs November
13th in, uh, in Braya and November,
November 14 in Oxnard.
Uh,
so you might want to check out one of
those shows. You know what I'm saying?
Uh, and, uh, oh,
and actually Brett's going to be on the
show in a couple of days when I get back
also. So, uh, so they,
so, uh, yeah, so we're,
I'm going to keep talking to
these guys who now, you know,
we definitely have some political diff
disagreements with and it's all good.
It's all good people. Um, okay, let's see.
Um,
there we go.
We got about 12 minutes left and
then I gotta I gotta get dressed.
I got to meet JP, ensure he's on his
like ate steak of the day. You know,
the guy's only eating steak and a,
and basically in club soda
and salt these days. Uh,
so he eats a tremendous amount of steak.
I'm Stilli,
I'm still doing this Paleo
thing as much as I can. Um,
but I've been eating a lot of state
cause I hang out with the guy that, uh,
let's see. Um, who do
you see running in 2020?
That has the power to actually unite the
country from where we're standing today?
Yeah.
I don't know.
I don't know if there is somebody
right now that can do it.
I don't think there's anyone in sort
of traditional politics that can do it.
Um, this isn't the right
answer, but I'll get,
I'll sort of throw this one
out is just like the idea, um,
if there was somebody that was like
a Schwartzenegger, now I don't,
it's not going to be him. And obviously
he wasn't even born in the United States,
so it's not a possibility.
But somebody that was basically a,
that had a certain amount of star power,
a little bit of political history.
He was the governor of
California obviously. Um,
and that was basically
a moderate Republican.
I think that would be the ticket to do
it, but it's not sure. It's an anger.
So I don't know. Is there
anyone else like that? Like,
I don't want it to be Clooney or just
like some actor that comes in and does it.
I don't think that's the right thing.
I don't know that there's anyone that's
a career politician at the moment.
It would have to be someone pretty,
pretty centrist that I think had a basic
belief in the constitution and wanted
to rein in government a little bit and,
and wasn't really playing
identity politics but,
but was willing to give the dems
something on the other side.
I don't know. I don't know who that is.
You got any good ideas? Let me know. Uh,
okay. Let's jump back in. So
we've got about 10 more minutes.
I'll take some more on a,
on super chat as well if you want to
just jump in there. Um, let's see.
Perhaps it's not just big
government that's the problem.
Perhaps it's big organizations prob
problem of imbalance of scale between an
organization, its power in the powers
of the individual. Well, look, this is,
this is why I love talking about the
youtube situation in the Google situation
so much because it's about, it's about
authoritative powers in the government.
Usually is the ultimate one of those,
right?
But when we have a company like Google
that controls the amount of information
and infrastructure and wires and
pipes and everything that they have,
of course they can become
a problem as well. I mean,
I've addressed that many times.
The issue is,
well then do you want to give more power
to the government to then decapitate
some of that power? That's
a, that's a tough question.
And I've heard good
arguments on both sides.
I tend to think the answer is no because
once you give power over to something,
be it the government or
a private organization,
it's very rare that it gives the
power back and there's always a unique
situation. So it's like Google
strikes me as a truly, truly,
truly unique situation,
but that's probably the same thing that
people said about Microsoft in 1987 or,
you know,
plenty of other things over the years.
So this is where I'm still more interested
in letting the market figure it out.
But does the,
could there be some touch
from the government that makes
some sense? Uh, you know,
I'm willing to have that conversation.
And you know,
that's say where Eric Weinstein,
we've discussed it on air, uh,
the last livestream came a
month or two ago. Um, so yeah,
there's good people on both sides of that.
And I think it's,
I think it's a totally fair
question. Um, let's see here.
I'll jump back into the patrion a moment.
Uh,
any advice on how I should
introduce my friends to the IDW?
Um, you know, I had found her,
one of the things that people
say to me all the time, uh,
when I meet people at these shows or come
up to you at the airport or whatever,
is that the,
the Prager u video,
why I left the left is I think it's
their number one video ever actually. Um,
and they had some major people on there
and it's, it's pretty awesome that it is.
And I think it sort of encapsulates
what initially brought the IDW together,
even though of course some of those folks
still consider themselves part of the
left, as I talked about earlier. Um,
I would say that that video, if you
can get that to somebody, look, it's,
it's pleasant. It's whatever it
is, three or four minutes. Um,
they don't have to agree with everything,
but I think I talk about
the right issues in a con,
in a competent and clear way that I
think will open them up to some of these
ideas. And then from there, uh,
then I would say you should
have them watch, you know,
it's like you want to kind of ease them
into some of this stuff I suppose. Um,
you know, another good one that,
well the video that we did,
our only animated video that we've ever
done, what is the classical liberal,
you could show them that. And then I think
that also could frame a little bit of,
uh, these issues for them. And then,
and then just sort of get them in
on some of these conversations. Um,
maybe my first conversation
with Sam Harris,
cause that's kind of where
it all started with me. Um,
pick one of the conversations with
Jordan Peterson. Um, you know,
any of the ones with Eric. Um, and then
there's the ones that are straight up,
less political.
Let's say.
You could have them listen
to the conversation with
Bret Weinstein as he was in
the midst of the evergreen situation or
the conversation with James Damore as he
was in the midst of the Google situation
or the conversation with Lindsay
Shepherd as she was in the midst of
the Wilfred Laurier situation. Um,
my conversation a couple of weeks with
Coleman Hughes I think is a good fit. Um,
you know,
I think more than anything else,
show people that there are some other
folks out there who are willing to talk,
who are willing to listen,
who don't want to braid and harangue and
dismantle society who are just trying
to figure it out just like they are.
And it's getting harder and harder and I
suspect it's going to just keep getting
harder and harder now.
You know, it's like,
there's no doubt right now that the
sides are just going to keep going.
So it's like those of us that want to
live with some people who are different
than us that don't think we have a right
to take from some and give to others
and all of that.
And I do think that's most of us,
those of us who want to live and let live,
those of us who don't care what your
neighbor smokes in his house or who your
other neighbors sleeping with or whatever
else, it's like that is most of us.
That is the beauty of America.
Everyone has come here from everywhere
for hundreds of years now and made a
better life for themselves.
You person watching this right now,
I guarantee you you have a better life.
If you live in America,
then your grandparents did. You can
say that with almost 99% certainty,
and if you don't, it's actually a
great argument against leftism too,
because they hate accumulated wealth
going out down from generation to
generation.
So if you screwed up,
if your grandparents were really
rich and you're really poor,
that's also a great argument for our evil,
capitalistic Patriarchy
because of accumulated wealth
doesn't always stay right.
So, uh, it's pretty damn good here.
And let's not forget that in the name
of trying to go for some Utopian society
that's never existed.
You can try to make it better,
but that doesn't mean you have
to destroy the whole damn thing.
It's a hell of lot easier to destroy
rather than create. So these people,
and that's one of the things,
it's like these people who
have never done anything,
all of these think piece writers and these
huff polarizers and buzzfeed writers,
they've never done anything.
They'd never hired anyone.
They've never created
anything. And it's like, Oh,
if only they could run the
world, everything would be okay.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Let's scale back the power that we have
over each other so that we can all live
as freely as possible,
and you can decide how much good
you want to do for your community,
for yourself or other people, et Cetera,
et cetera. Um, that you could argue,
I suppose it's a little utopian,
but it's Utopian within the
confines of us having to be free.
And then we can discuss on the margins
how much should we be taxed because I do
believe we have to be taxed.
How much should we have for defense or
how much should we have her, this or that?
How much would should we
have for infrastructure?
Can some of this be done by a
private enterprise, etc. Etc.
These are all the things we can discuss.
And I think you guys that are watching
or listening to this do want to discuss
these things and you want
to get to mature answers.
So I'm going to keep doing the people
that I think, uh, have the right answers,
or at least our thinking about the
right answers are willing to have
conversations about the right
answers. All right, let's see. Uh,
someone that I think Dwayne, the Rock
Johnson would be great. You know,
a couple people have
tweeted that at me lately.
I don't know exactly
where his politics are,
but could he be the type of person that
comes from the and Schwartzenegger or
mold? Almost literally in this
case maybe, but like it, right.
Does it all have to be so celebrity-driven
and what does that really say about
society? I'm not sure. Oh,
and someone said, Bro, force,
awesome side scrolling multiplayer
shooter. I haven't, uh, it's totally fun.
I've been playing, you know, four
player, especially when you're,
you're playing with a couple of friends.
It's just like complete
chaos and nuttiness uh,
it's almost like a little too much for
me cause there's so many explosions
happening at the exact
same time. Um, okay.
Let me tell you a little bit
about, uh, some career stuff
that's a, that's cooking.
So there's a lot of good things cooking.
And as I said, being on this tour with,
uh, with Jordan has, it's been
light, it truly life changing.
I've enjoyed every second of it.
Um, I've connected with people ice.
Last night in Denmark,
I saw Flemming Rose Fleming Guaipe had
on the show who is the publisher of in
the Danish magazine of the Mohammad
cartoons. I think that was 2003.
Um, he is, uh,
a spectacular advocate for free speech
and free expression and just the most
decent warm guy you're ever going to meet.
Uh,
so I had dinner with him last night. I
had dinner with Douglas Murray last week.
I'm going to try to see Majid maybe
tomorrow. I've connected with old friends,
high school friends. I've, I've gone
out with fans after the show. Um,
I've met all sorts of people. I'm,
I'm really just having a blast. I,
I feel good as long as,
as long as I keep basically eating
right and trying to get to the gym.
Every now and again.
I've been walking around these cities.
It's giving me perspective on the world.
You know,
I never thought I was going to go
to all of these countries like this.
And even though some of
them are only for a day,
it's like you get a little flavor
of how other people, you know,
you see just differently or look
differently or whatever it is.
It's been totally inspiring and I
think it's, I think it's helping.
It's helping me sharpen my,
my tools to do what I do.
And hopefully I can do maybe
more international shows.
And I think actually if Jordan and I
do end up extending this into march and
April,
which it sounds like we will,
I'm thinking about doing more shows
on the road. Like really we'll,
we'll start renting, uh, you know,
[inaudible] that whole thing. Uh,
but I do get some great news last week.
So you guys know,
or most of you know that I've been
talking about this book forever. Um, so I,
I haven't,
uh,
I don't want to give you too much right
this moment cause there will be an
announcement I think in about a week or
so. Um, but my book has been picked up.
It is by a Primo, Primo
publisher. And the whole thing,
the way the whole deal has worked out is,
is beyond a dream come true.
Uh, I'm working on it. We're,
I don't want to give you publishing dates
and all that yet. Um, but I'm super,
super site. Uh, it's a, uh, this thing's
going to be a frequent labor or love.
Um,
a lot of it also for me was I wanted
to get through this current election,
uh, because I wanted to publish it
sometime between the midterms and the
presidential election.
Not that it's purely about politics,
but I thought there'll be an interesting
moment for the country in there. Uh,
so now that we're past that, I can focus
in on, on it a little bit different,
but we have a closed the
deal with publishers. So I'm
really psyched about that.
And that's one of the ancillary benefits
I think of doing this show with, uh,
this tour with Jordan because it's like
I'm willing to bust my ass to promote it
and do the right thing and get back out
on the road and, and share these ideas.
And I gotta tell you, there's one other
thing about Jordan. I mean, you know,
he says it often because it
comes up in the Q and A's.
We do about a 40 minute Q and a at the
end of the show. And people will ask, um,
you know, like, do you ever get tired
or, or are you, how do you stay inspired?
And he's like,
he's like,
I'm sharing my ideas all over the world
and millions of people are buying my
books and I come to speak to
thousands of great people like you.
Like what could be better than this?
And you know,
I get a little of that extra glow from,
from his people,
but I get it from you guys all the time.
And this thing is continually growing and
I'm doing the best I can and I'll make
mistakes along the way.
But, uh, you know, I think,
I think we're on to something
really great. And I,
since we're just at the beginning again,
which is crazy because how could that be?
But maybe that's sort of what life is.
You keep working and working
and working in this somehow.
Don't always know what you're
working for. And then there's, whoa,
there's a new beginning and then you go
this way and then there's another new
beginning and you go this way.
But if you,
if you do what you can do with a little,
with some rigor and some passion and
some honesty, I think good things,
good things come. I guess that Peterson
guy has worn off a warrant on maven that,
um, all right guys, we did
about an hour. Uh, I got to a,
I got to get myself ready for the
big show in Birmingham tonight. Uh,
we will be in Oslo tomorrow.
We are in Denmark the day after that
and then we are in Finland the day after
that.
And then I take a crazy stop
flight 12 hours some situation,
uh, back to la on the 12th. Uh,
Braya stand up on the 13th link is right
down below Oxnard on the 14th link is
right down below.
And then there's some other standup
stuff that's listed in there and all that
good stuff. Anyway, thanks
as always. And uh, okay.
I'm going to enjoy my hotel room for
15 minutes before I go meet Jordan.
All right, Ciao guys. See Ya.